Apple has just revealed the iPhone 11
Pro and while some people are
disappointed with it it's still the most
unique and powerful iPhone Apple has
ever made there's just one question that
remains should you upgrade to the iPhone
11 Pro if you already have an iPhone 10
or an iPhone 10 s let's first take a
look at a bit of history the iPhone 10
was the best-selling smartphone in the
first quarter of 2018 and it continued
to do pretty well for the rest of the
year so that means a lot of people
bought the iPhone 10 but when the iPhone
10s came out it was pretty underwhelming
in fact a silver iPhone 10 looks almost
identical to a silver iPhone 10s and
people want to see and feel a difference
when they're upgrading and that's the
reason why a lot of people skipped out
on the 10s most of the people who
upgraded actually went with the Tenace
max model because of the larger size
which made it easy to feel the
difference between the two and now comes
the iPhone 11 pro and pro max and
because of that large square bump in
triple cameras on the back you and other
people will instantly be able to tell
that it's an iPhone 11 Pro and that's
what really matters even though most
people don't want to admit it not only
that but the glass is now in a matte
finish for the first time ever so you
can actually feel the difference every
day however $1000 is a big price to pay
so let's compare the 11pro to both the
iPhone 10 and iPhone 10's starting with
the 10 when we compared the cameras of
the 10 and 10's there was a massive
improvement due to Smart HD our newer
sensors in the knurl engine so there's
no doubt that you'll instantly notice a
difference coming from the 10 you'll
also get the ultra wide-angle lens and
much better portrait blur photos with
depth control and portrait lighting of
course there's also the new night mode
as well dynamic range is also gonna
improve by a massive amount in video
recording for both the rear and selfie
cameras and the iPhone 11 Pro finally
gets a huge selfie camera upgrade that
allows it to shoot much better selfies
in 4k video at up to 60fps which is
insane the display has also improved on
the 10s and it's improving even more
with at 11 Pro with better contrast and
brightness you'll also get
four-and-a-half hours more battery life
with the 11pro in a huge six-and-a-half
hours
or battery life with the 11pro max which
could probably be enough by itself for
some people to upgrade the a12 Bionic
chip and the 10's was a great
improvement over the 10 so going from
the tens 11 ship to the 8 13 ship in the
11pro will actually be noticeable
especially for gaming water resistance
goes up as well from half an hour in
only up to three feet of water to 13
feet of water PSID speed was upgraded on
the 10s and it's being upgraded again on
the 11pro to work even faster at greater
angles and from further away which i
think matters even more than speed
you're getting much faster LTE and Wi-Fi
speed and much better and louder
speakers as well along with a bunch of
other features like dual SIM and last
but definitely not least you finally get
an 18 watt fast charger in the box so to
be completely honest you definitely will
feel a difference if you upgrade from
the 10 to the 11 Pro especially if you
go for the 11 Pro max now what if you
already have the iPhone 10s this time
around you'll see and feel a difference
because of the square camera bump and
the matte glass back but is it worth
upgrading again I don't think so I
currently have the 10s max and I'm
personally going to upgrade but that's
mostly because we need the latest
iPhones to make YouTube videos but for
you I don't think it's worth it the
speakers are already great the speed of
the a12 chip is already really fast and
more than fast enough for any game the
LTE and Wi-Fi speeds are good enough and
the cameras are honestly excellent for
my needs
yes you get night mode in an ultra wide
lens with the 11pro but that's not that
big of a deal the five hours of extra
battery life sounds tempting especially
for gaming but my tennis max already
lasts me all day the main differences
you'll notice on a day to day basis are
the upgraded selfie camera more reliable
face ID faster charger extra camera lens
and extra battery life but are those
things worth upgrading again honestly no
now if Apple got rid of the knotch that
would be a whole nother story if this
video helps you out make sure to tap
that like button and click the circle
above to subscribe and check out some of
our other videos right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you
the next video